[Música]
bienvenidos a nuestra sección para
hablar de economía aquí en directo
américa hoy nos acompaña nuestro
periodista jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido buenas noches y comencemos
con lo último del foro económico mundial
que se ha hablado bueno ahí se abordó un
posible embargo al petróleo ruso el
ministro alemán de economía robert huff
dijo estar convencido que la unión
europea alcanzará este veto de las
importaciones de petróleo ruso
próximamente avec dijo que este acuerdo
podría cerrarse en los próximos días
aunque aún está por verse porque hungría
se niega a desbloquear este nuevo
paquete de sanciones la comisión europea
propuso eliminar las importaciones de
petróleo ruso para finales de año en la
mayoría de los estados miembros del del
bloque aunque para hungría y otros
países con mayor dependencia tendría más
tiempo para dejar de usar estos
hidrocarburos esto dijo el ministro en
davos sobre los problemas económicos
también que enfrenta el mundo escuchamos
y listo
creo que ahora mismo tenemos al menos
cuatro problemas o crisis que están
entrelazadas tenemos una alta inflación
en algunos países de europa en eeuu y en
muchos otros países tenemos una crisis
energética que hay que llamarla así
tenemos pobreza alimentaria y tenemos la
crisis climática y no podemos resolver
los problemas si sólo nos concentramos
en una de las crisis pero si no se
resuelve ninguno de los problemas
metemos realmente que nos encontramos
con una recesión mundial con un efecto
tremendo no sólo sobre la protección del
clima y la acción climática sino de la
estabilidad mundial en general
y los hidrocarburos no fueron el único
tema del foro de davos allí también se
habló de la alimentación en el mundo
cuál es el panorama jorge el director
ejecutivo del programa mundial de
alimentos de naciones unidas david
bradley dijo el martes que la guerra en
ucrania está provocando una crisis
alimentaria sea un funcionario las
personas que están en riesgo de hambruna
a nivel mundial pasaron de 80 millones a
276 millones en los últimos 4 o 5 años a
escuchemos
creo que hay un extraordinario despertar
de la realidad a la que nos enfrentamos
que realmente es una crisis alimentaria
mundial no había visto eso antes el año
pasado intentaba decir a todo el mundo
en las diferentes ciudades que tenemos
problemas que tenemos problemas pero
nadie parecía querer centrarse ahora
todo el mundo está empezando a prestarle
la atención que necesita porque las
consecuencias si no lo haces van a ser
absolutamente horribles ya sabes
y eeuu dejará que expire la licencia de
pago de la deuda rusa qué significa esto
bueno esta decisión podría acercar a
moscú al default en momentos en que
washington lo presiona más tras la
invasión en ucrania el departamento del
tesoro de eeuu comunicó que no
prorrogaría una licencia que expira este
miércoles y que permitiría a rusia
realizar pagos de su deuda soberana
estadounidense esta exención permitía a
moscú seguir pagando los intereses y el
principal para evitar el impago de su
deuda pública que asciende a 2 mil
millones de dólares en pagos que vencen
hasta final de año de sus bonos
internacionales hasta ahora rusia ha
pagado sus bonos pese a las sanciones
que tiene rusia actualmente ronda los 40
mil millones de dólares en bonos
internacionales en circulación en otros
temas la unión europea podría llegar
pronto a un acuerdo sobre un impuesto
mínimo global a las grandes
corporaciones así lo adelantó el
ministro francés de economía bruno le
maire polonia es el único país que se
resiste a este plan
europa aceptó después que en abril vetar
a un compromiso para poner marcha a este
acuerdo de 137 países alcanzados en
octubre pasado la aceptación de polonia
es esencial para que el acuerdo sigue
adelante escuchemos la convicción que
tuvo un hardware estoy convencido de que
podemos llegar a un acuerdo antes del 17
de junio con hungría y polonia creo que
estamos en proceso de eliminar los
obstáculos que ahora existían en
relación con un consenso sobre el
impuesto mínimo de sociedades quiero
reiterar que esta medida es de justicia
si queremos luchar contra la
optimización fiscal si queremos luchar
contra la evasión fiscal debemos aplicar
este impuesto mínimo a las empresas de
acción física al sombrerito y contó el
liberation fiscal del fondo desde texas
o minimal a la puso y sus 7 jorge
cuéntenos cuáles son los indicadores del
día empezamos en wall street que cerró
en terreno mixto luego de que snap está
de esta aplicación divulgar a sus malas
perspectivas de negocio y arrastrará en
su caída al sector tecnológico en europa
la bolsa española se ubicó subió un poco
apoyada por el alza de la mayoría de los
bancos y a pesar de la en wall street y
en américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
avanzó pese a la caída del 3% de las
acciones de la petrolera petrobras
después de que el gobierno brasileño
anunciara un nuevo presidente para el
estatal en el segundo en poco más de un
mes jorge gracias por toda la
información económica y a ustedes los
invitamos a que sigan con nosotros
viendo el debate